turning now to another big issue in the
election the coronavirus crisis some
hospitals in wisconsin say they're close
to being overwhelmed by a surge in
patients
and the average number of cases is
rising in 28
states georgia's governor has extended
coveted restrictions in his state
but just over the state line in
neighboring florida many people went
straight to their favorite bars after
the state repealed
it's most of its rules our lead national
correspondent david begno
is following the pandemic here in new
york city david good morning to you good
morning to you look florida is a mecca
for the cruise industry most of the
cruise lines are based there
people fly there get on a ship and take
off but there has been a no sail order
in place because of coronavirus
the new york times is now reporting the
cdc director wanted to extend that no
sale order
through february but the white house
blocked it
tourism is crucial to florida's economy
which the governor of florida wants to
fully reload
florida's nightlife is heating up after
governor ron desantis
officially ended all coveted related
business regulations last week
they have a right to operate he also
effectively ended local government's
abilities to enforce
mask mandates by suspending fines for
rule breakers
on the streets of tampa very few people
appeared to be wearing masks on monday
after the city's hockey team won the
stanley cup
but businesses can still require
customers to wear masks
which has caused some confusion at the
newly reopened nightclubs
we were holding people back from coming
in we were asking to wear the mask
they were confused they thought that
they did not have to wear the mask
the rules are a little different in
miami-dade county the most populated
county in the state
the governor is allowing leaders there
to enforce their mass mandate
and place tougher restrictions on bars
and restaurants
despite that some public health experts
like dr eileen marty
are deeply concerned he's putting the
entire state
at risk of having another major outbreak
we're not
at suppression levels anywhere in
florida not really
according to data from johns hopkins
university florida's test positivity
rate is still more than 10 percent that
is
well above the recommended level for
reopening the test positivity rate is
above 10 percent
in more than a dozen other states
including wisconsin
our first responsibility is to keep
students safe there teachers union
leaders
gathered at the state's capital
wednesday demanding an end to
all in-person learning covet
hospitalizations in wisconsin are at
record highs
and one official at this green bay
hospital says the number of coronavirus
patients there
is more than double what it was earlier
in the pandemic
you may be one of the lucky ones who
doesn't know
anybody who's had covet or hasn't lost
anybody
but i guarantee you before this is over
you will
let's talk vaccines the president
continues to say a vaccine will be
available in weeks
leading health experts say it's going to
be well in the next year in fact
the ceo of moderna which has a leading
vaccine candidate in process right now
says he doesn't think it'll be available
to anyone who wants one until well in
this
the spring of 2021. and gail one more
thing before we go standing here in
times square i want you to know those
people who say
new york city is dying it's not it may
seem a little quieter
but this city is still very much alive
as we move forward
okay david we want the city to be very
much alive but also we want the people
to be alive too
it's so hard to understand why people
doubt the science
in terms of what the mask can do saving
your life i'm so glad to see that you
wear one
all the time when you're outside it's an
important message to send
every day my friend david stay healthy
thank you always good to see you